405 pénurie de médicaments en 2016
1200 en 2019 une évolution alarmante du
manque de traitements disponibles en
france qui pourrait s'aggraver selon les
prévisions de la nsn l'agencé nationale
de sécurité du médicament en 2020 2400
rupture pourrait être constatée une
carence qui concerne notamment des
médicaments dits d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur c'est à dire pour lesquels une
interruption de traitement peut mettre
en jeu le pronostic vital du patient
en revanche les molécules récente plus
coûteuses ne serait pas impacter sur 140
médicaments en rupture de stock en 2020
les trois quarts serait des traitements
commercialisé depuis plus de 20 ans
vendu moins de 25 euros
donc peu rentables
et face aux pénuries la réponse des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques est
insuffisante selon ufc que choisir parmi
celles proposées administrer un autre
médicament même si cela peut entraîner
des effets secondaires ou diminuer la
posologie
mais dans un cas sur cinq les
industriels ne proposerait aucune
solution
de son côté la fédération du médicament
dément cette étude sur les 1500 quatre
signalements recensés en 2019
environ un tiers ont conduit à des
mesures de gestion des situations de
tension entre la rsm et les entreprises
conduisant finalement à un nombre limité
de véritables ruptures de stock mais
forte de ces chiffres l'association ufc
que choisir en appelle à l'état
elle réclame d'instaurer l'obligation
pour les laboratoires de constituer des
stocks et de développer une production
publique de médicaments pour assurer la
production de ce délaissé par les
laboratoires
[Musique]